[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela Buen día para
ustedes Hola Buenos días Ángela pues
vamos a empezar con el dueño de Twitter
que anunció ahora medidas para
contrarrestar los llamados Bots de qué
se trata pues esto es lo que ha querido
hacer desde que lo compró la red social
El Magnate y los moscas quien esta vez
dijo que en su cuenta personal que a
partir del próximo 15 de abril solamente
las cuentas verificadas es decir las que
pagan una cuota de 7 dólares al mes van
a poder aparecer en la sección de
recomendaciones que se llama for you o
para ti y así también podrán votar en
las encuestas de la red social dice que
esa es la única forma realista de
abordar el control de los enjambres de
Bots de Inteligencia artificial
avanzados como los llama pues de lo
contrario es una batalla perdida sin
esperanza esa iniciativa se produce
apenas dos días después de que mosca
asegurara en una nota interna a sus
empleados que el valor de la empresa se
ha reducido a 20 mil millones de dólares
menos de la mitad de los 44 mil millones
de dólares que él pagó por su compra el
pasado mes de octubre Daniela en otras
noticias hoy comparecen los reguladores
de Estados Unidos ante el congreso por
la quiebra de bancos gran tema que
seguimos desarrollando sí ángeles que
sigue siendo noticia en todo el mundo
están llamados hoy ante el comité de
supervisión del senado y de la cámara
mañana ante la cámara el presidente de
la corporación Federal de seguros de
depósitos Martin greenberg y el
vicepresidente de la junta de
gobernadores de la reserva Federal
Michael vara la Fed anticipó lo que va a
decir este último va a decir que el
sistema financiero estadounidense es
Sólido y resistente que los depósitos de
la gente están a salvo y que el único
culpable de la caída de silicon fue la
propia gerencia del banco que no supo
manejar de manera prudente las tasas de
interés y el riesgo de liquidez además
se comprometerá públicamente a revisar
exhaustivamente sus políticas en un
interno Pues por evitar
colapsos según este anticipo que entregó
el Banco Central del discurso de para
los formuladores de políticas también
los reguladores y los analistas han
enfatizado mucho en que la situación de
ahora no es una repetición de la crisis
financiera de 2008 escuchemos
lo que hemos visto son lecciones
aprendidas del pasado ahora todos
recordamos la gran crisis financiera y
la crisis bancaria de entonces muy
diferente a la de hoy y la Fed Está
tratando de dejar eso muy claro
la federación de seguros de depósitos y
el departamento del tesoro están
tratando de enviar un mensaje
contundente Mira esta no es una crisis
crediticia como en 2008 entonces donde
hemos visto debilidad bancaria hemos
visto también respuestas muy rápidas
para que otras instituciones entren se
fusionen con estos activos y los asuman
Estados Unidos demandó a la mayor
empresa de criptomonedas seguimos
hablando del mercado de valores porque
la comisión de comercio de futuros de
productos básicos demandó a la empresa y
su fundador ni consejero delegado
la acusación que pesa en su contra ante
un tribunal de Chicago es por supuesta
evasión deliberada de la legislación
estadounidense Pues dice que el
organismo
vainas esquivó su responsabilidad al no
haberse registrado en esta comisión esto
es un paso necesario para llevar a cabo
sus actividades de compra y venta de
criptomonedas en el país concretamente
la demanda asegura que desde julio de
2019 vainas ha ofrecido operaciones con
derivados a usuarios de este país a
pesar de que en teoría no podía hacerlo
y que no requería ningún tipo de
identificación para estos clientes
también en violación de las normas
vigentes Pues esta empresa está en la
mira también de otro reguladores como
por ejemplo la comisión de valores
también el servicio interno de impuestos
o varios Fiscales federales la compañía
calificó estos señalamientos de
inesperados y decepcionantes lo cierto
Es que las criptomonedas siguen estando
en el punto de mirada de las autoridades
y en otros temas china se defiende de un
informe del Banco Mundial de qué se
trata Daniela pues Ángela un estudio
liderado por este organismo multilateral
dice que china gastó 240 mil millones de
dólares para rescatar a 22 países en
desarrollo entre 2008 y 2021 estos
préstamos se concentran principalmente
en aquellas naciones de medianos
ingresos como por ejemplo Argentina
Pakistán o Egipto sin embargo el informe
calificó estos préstamos de opacos y
descoordinados tanto a entender que su
desembolso podría estar condicionado por
ejemplo a criterios políticos Beijing
salió en su defensa
china actúa de acuerdo con las leyes del
mercado y las normas internacionales
respeta la voluntad de los países
pertinentes nunca ha obligado a ninguna
de las partes a pedir dinero prestado no
impondrá ninguna condición política Los
acuerdos de préstamo y no busca ningún
interés político propio ahora vamos a
hablar de el sector Avícola Daniela que
es el más importante de Egipto y que
está en problemas mucho de esto hemos
oído en las últimas semanas así es
Ángela y hay que decir que Egipto es un
importante comprador de productos
básicos Así que es bastante importante
también para nuestra región de América
Latina que es exportadora de estos
productos pues este país ha estado
sufriendo una crisis de Divisas que hizo
que la libra se desplomara casi en un
50% frente al dólar en los últimos meses
esto que hizo reprimir las importaciones
y llevar la inflación anual al 31,9%
Este es un nivel más alto en cinco años
y medio el gobierno trató de frenar los
precios con importaciones de maíz y de
pollo precisamente de Brasil pero estos
Todavía están muy encima de los niveles
del año pasado y la producción de pollos
que es un alimento clave en Egipto ha
bajado casi a la mitad desde octubre
todo esto en pleno mes del ramadán que
se ha convertido en un lujo el consumo
de pollo
Este es el peor periodo en años para la
industria Avícola desde noviembre pasado
hasta ahora no hay estabilidad en los
precios de los piensos ni en los precios
de los pollitos quienes querían pollos
se enfrentan muchos problemas no pueden
implementar un sistema
hay una gran diferencia entre el año
pasado y este año el ramad han pasado un
kilo de pollo no costaba más de 30
libras egipcias un dólar ahora cuesta
más de 90 libras egipcias unos 3 dólares
Pues bien Daniela llegamos al final de
este segmento de economía y se le parece
bien Vamos a darle paso a los deportes
Así es cuando